FEMALE SPEAKER: So our
next speaker, Yasmin Green,
who is our head of
strategy and operations
for Google Ideas-- and her fun
fact is that in her spare time,
she's taken up
filmmaking-- seems
to be a common theme
today-- and she's currently
location scouting
for a-- and I just
want to get it right-- for an
absurdist and modern technology
take on the folk tale
of Aladdin, which
should be pretty cool.
I'm pretty excited.
And now I have the blue genie
in my head with Robin Williams.
And so with that,
I give you Yasmin.
YASMIN GREEN: Hi.
Hi, everyone.
I thought we could actually
get started by me showing you
a video clip of an event
that we arranged in my group,
Google Ideas, called 'Conflict
in a Connected World.' So maybe
we could dim the lights
and show that video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-The internet was designed
for, and has proven to have,
an incredibly positive
impact on the world.
It was designed with an
aspirational optimism
that remains.
But we need to
adapt our tool set
to the realities of the world.
-Today, access to the internet
equals freedom of expression,
and it should be considered
a basic human right.
However, wavered the controls
information has always
been a priority for
the Cuba dictatorship,
as most dictatorships.
-In 2009, when there were a
contested election, [INAUDIBLE]
became a place where people
expressed dissatisfaction
they want in government.
And in a matter of four
months, it got blocked.
-There have been
more than 70,000 URLs
blocked in Thailand.
When people express opinion
about the king on the internet,
they can get
bullied, and they are
risky of going to jail
for up to 15 years.
-Because of their limited
access to the internet,
humans have resource to offline
lines, like USB flash memories
and DVDs, to share information.
It's important that they
know what really goes on
in their country, and
it's also important
that they know what
goes on in the world.
-Conflict has existed
since the dawn of time,
but we're just now seeing how
closely digital technology is
starting to influence the
way that different forms
of conflict play out.
Things that happen
offline are impacting
how people react and
share content online,
which in turn impacts
offline events.
-During the
revolution, I covered
what was happening in
[INAUDIBLE] over the internet.
I was arrested and tortured
in the Interior Ministry
for five days.
I think that social
networks and the internet
was the most important factor
in the Tunisian revolution.
-Since January of
2013, the Syrian regime
launched at least 150
scud missiles on people.
So we built Aymta, which
is the online warning
system for people who
live in the targeted areas
so they can go to the shelter.
That service made the
Syrian regime angry.
After 10 days, we had this
massively huge DDoS attack
throw us offline.
-Attacks against the users, the
servers, and the infrastructure
of the internet are increasing.
The reality is that the next
generation of internet users
is going to experience
more turbulence,
and we need to figure out
how they can be protected.
-As technology changes,
the law doesn't always
catch up quite fast enough.
If we want people to
have freedom online,
we absolutely have to
keep fighting for it.
-My hope for future generations
are very simple-- access
to the internet,
access to information,
access to freedom of expression.
When they can communicate
among themselves,
eventually that will
lead to freedom.
[END PLAYBACK]
Oh, thanks.
I hope you enjoyed that video.
It always inspires me.
Slim Amamou-- we
saw him on the clip.
He talked about being arrested
and tortured in Tunisia.
He's probably one of the most
inspirational people that
I've met in the
last few years. .
He's a Tunisian programmer,
blogger, and internet activist.
And he was arranging street
protests for internet freedoms
and getting arrested
several times
before the protests that led
to the Jasmine Revolution,
where he was arrested
and tortured.
And after his release,
interestingly-- two days
after in January of
2011, he was actually
appointed to be Secretary
of State for Sport and Youth
for the interim Tunisian
government, which
sounds magnificent
other than the fact
that by May of that same
year, he had resigned.
Because of army pressure
on the government,
internet censorship had resumed.
So Slim is one of many pioneers
on the forefront-- I mean,
on the front lines
of revolution.
But I found him
particularly inspirational.
And he said something
that really stuck with me.
I asked him, "What advice do
you have for other people that
are thinking about challenging
their governments?"
And he said, "If you
aren't tech savvy,
you aren't effective
because you're not safe."
And that's really
relevant to what
I'd like to talk
to you about today.
How many people before they saw
the agenda for today's event
had heard of Google Ideas?
By show of hands-- OK.
Maybe a quarter, so that's good.
I'm looking forward to telling
you more about what we do.
The starting premise
is that there
is a nexus between
technology and geopolitics,
and world affairs
increasingly have
a digital and a
physical component
that come hand-in-hand.
So when we started at Google
Ideas three years ago,
it was our intention
to bring together
users and experts,
but also engineers,
to see technology initiatives
that would help the people that
are living through conflict
and instability and repression.
That's why I'm really
excited to be here today,
because I assume
that every one of us
is really passionate
about technology
and also about geopolitics.
The question I have is how
many of us think of them
or work on them in tandem?
And if the answer
isn't everyone,
then that's something
that I'd love to change.
So let's start by taking
a look at the problem.
This is a map created by Freedom
House, who are a US-based NGO.
According to Freedom House,
two out of every three people
in the world faces some type
of repression, either online
or offline.
And for one out of
every three people,
that repression is severe.
And without trivializing
the devastating impact
of censorship and
authoritarianism,
those things aren't really new.
They've been around since
the beginning of time.
So what is new?
The way connected
technologies are
changing how they
manifest themselves.
Our beloved internet-- it's
been around since-- well,
it's been around since
longer than that.
It's been changing lives
really since the mid-1990s,
even though only 16 million
people used it then.
Since that time, a
whopping 2.7 billion people
have come online, and they've
used a suite of devices, most
recently PCs and desktops,
mobiles, tablets, wearables.
And social platforms
have completely exploded.
So not many of us would
get to quarter past 2:00
PM in the afternoon without
interacting with a social media
platform at least once.
But social has really ushered
unprecedented usage patterns.
On average, every
single second--
that's every single
second-- 100 hours of video
are uploaded to YouTube, half
a million tweets are sent
on Twitter, and-- this is
whopping-- 10 million photos
are served on Facebook
in a single second.
So that's really astounding.
And of course, that pace of
change is not decelerating.
And we're only at the 2.7
billion people online mark.
In the next decade,
we could be joined
by another five billion people.
And guess what?
They're disproportionately
coming online in environments
where states are weak,
rule of law is strained,
and the youth are the majority
and largely unemployed.
So there's a real risk that
while repression and conflict
persist in the physical world,
as the next five billion
come online, they
manifest themselves
in entirely new forms
on the internet.
So at Google, we
like to aim big,
and we talk about something
called a "moon shot."
Has anyone heard that
term, moon shot, before?
Raise your hand if you have.
I will ask you.
OK.
What do you think
a moon shot is?
AUDIENCE: You mean in Google?
YASMIN GREEN: No.
Anything-- in non-Google.
AUDIENCE: In non-Google?
Something that is
technologically possible
but not yet foreseen.
It's not foreseen in
how you would get there.
YASMIN GREEN: Yeah, exactly.
You have a kind of
an idea that makes
you think that you can achieve
something really outrageous.
AUDIENCE: And you feel excited.
YASMIN GREEN: And
you feel excited.
That's perfect.
So it originated
from Project Apollo,
which was-- President JFK
proposed a national goal
to Congress in 1961 to
send a man to the moon
and have him return safely.
And that was thought
to be audacious
and actually impossible.
And he proposed for it to be
done by the end of the 1960s,
and it indeed was done by 1969.
So that's kind our inspiration
when we talk about moon shots.
And our moon shot
at Google Ideas
is this-- to end repressive
censorship by 2024.
So let's take a look at what
that looks like in practice.
Here's out map.
Freedom House-- we said they
look at print and internet
and broadcast media, and
they rank all countries
in the world-- so
all 197 countries--
according to press freedoms.
And of course, press freedom
is an indispensable requirement
for democracy.
So of all of these 197
countries, coming in at 191--
so that's six from the
very bottom-- was Iran.
I am Iranian.
I was born in Iran, and I
have friends and family who
are there, and I think that I
have a pretty good familiarity
with the Iranian digital
repression toolkit,
so I want to take you
through it really fast.
The first go-to tactic actually
of any repressive regime
is the blocking of websites.
So any site that's
thought to be associated
with free expression, like
Facebook, YouTube, Twitter--
those are blocked.
Independent media, human
rights advocacy, those
are also blocked.
But a real hallmark of
Iranian digital repression
is throttling-- so
deliberately slowing down
the internet to when it gets
so painfully, visibly slow
that people just give up trying.
And the minister in Iran for
communication and technology
is actually on record as saying
that the Iranian government
deliberately slowed
down the internet
at the time of the last
presidential election.
So news like the ex-two term
president being disqualified
from running, or really anything
about the eight candidates
that were approved to run--
none of that information
could be found for users that
were trying to look online.
But one of the most alarming
tactics the Iranian government
uses is something called
man in the middle.
That's manipulating your
own information traffic.
So any time that
your information
is going through hardware
or software that's
being controlled by a
government or a corrupt ISP,
they can manipulate
that traffic.
And last year, pro-regime
activists in Iran--
they created an imitation
version of the BBC's website.
The aesthetics were identical--
same font, same layout,
same everything.
But just the odd
story was replaced
with something that was
more like propaganda
for the Islamic republic.
So on the BBC's website--
or this fake BBC--
you could see articles like
'Death of bin Laden Fabricated
by Washington,' or 'BBC
Colluding with Israel to Attack
Iran.' And users in Iran
would try to visit bbc.co.uk
and automatically get
redirected to the fake BBC,
and they just wouldn't know.
So the motivation was to deceive
people, and it really worked.
The good news,
however, is that there
are tools to protect users
such as those in Iran,
and they're called proxies.
By show of hands,
how many people
here have used a proxy before?
OK, that's incredible-- 90%.
Likely to be a lot
lower, I think,
in a less technical audience.
So you know that proxies
redirect your connection
through a computer
that isn't subjected
to the same repressive tactics.
So you 90% are in
very good company,
and I'd like to just
pause for a second
and highlight a bit
of an irony here.
Some of the most prominent
users of proxies in Iran
are actually the supreme leader.
So this is the most
powerful man in Iran
and, arguably, the entire
Shiite Muslim world.
He uses proxies to add to
his photo album online.
I follow him [INAUDIBLE].
The recently elected
president, Hassan Rouhani,
tweets to his 170,000
Twitter followers
presumably using a proxy because
Twitter is blocked in Iran.
And this is the biggest
social media power
user you'll come across-- the
Foreign Minister, Javad Zarif,
who has 824,000
likes on Facebook.
So these are three of the
most prominent leaders in Iran
who are using-- who actually
were not on social media at all
a year ago, and are now
using proxies, sometimes
on a daily basis, to circumvent
the same severe digital
repression that they impose
on all of their people.
That's 21st century
statecraft in Iran for you.
So in theory, you
have these proxies
that allow people to access
the internet through more
safe, less blocked,
more private means.
But in practice, they
face two challenges.
The first is scale.
So unlike traditional
technologies
where the more
people that use them,
the more people that use them--
positive network effects--
with proxies, the more people
that use them, the more likely
they are to be
detected and shut down.
The other challenge is trust.
Because they're
anonymous, you don't
know who's providing your
proxy, and you don't who's
using your server as a proxy.
And that's a problem.
So it's widely believed
that in the Iranian bazaar,
the majority of proxies
that are on sale
are being provided by the
Iranian Revolutionary Guard.
So ostensibly they
say they're going
to speed up your
internet connection.
And then when something
politically sensitive
happens in the country, they
start blocking and throttling
and manipulating traffic.
So if you are an
Iranian, you have
to choose-- don't access
the worldwide web,
or access it through a proxy
that's provided by someone
that you don't know.
And the surprising thing
is that every Iranian I
know who uses the internet
does so using a proxy that they
couldn't possibly have faith in.
So at Google Ideas, we
spend a lot of time thinking
about the challenges faced by
people in places like Iran,
and also the
opportunities that are
presented by connected
technologies.
And an interesting
insight occurred.
Most of the people
that we spoke to who
are living in these
repressive environments
had a friend or a
family member that they
trust who lives abroad,
that they already
communicate online with.
So let me just check here.
How many people---
by show of hands,
how many people in this room
have somebody that they trust
that lives in a country
that's colored in black, red,
or orange?
Fantastic.
That's practically everybody.
Great.
So that insight is what is
at the heart of a product
that we are launching
called uProxy.
And the insight is what if we
could give every person who
lives in a repressive
environment
the technology-- in this
case, a browser extension--
to be able to communicate with
somebody who lives outside
of their firewall, somebody
they already trust?
So this intermediation
and trust risks
aren't there through a
means that's really simple.
And uProxy is a
browser extension
in Chrome and in Firefox.
And also, we're going
to build it for Android.
You download it like you
would any other extension.
You can log in to a
chat through, let's say,
G+ or Facebook.
And as long as the
person that you
trust who's on the other
side of the national border
has that same
extension, you can now
exchange not just photos
and jokes online-- actually,
your internet experience--
your less restricted access
to the internet.
And that really is probably
in my eight years at Google--
this is the product that
I am the most-- I mean
it has personal
resonance for me--
but the product that I'm
the most excited about.
But our moon shot
has several steps.
So what if those users that are
trying to access information
find that when they get
there, that information has
been taken offline
in the first place?
So let me give you a few
examples from recent real world
events.
Several regimes
across the world are
being challenged by protests.
This is Thailand.
This is Ukraine.
This is Venezuela.
Hundreds of thousands of
protesters on the streets,
and in many cases, those
protests are turning bloody.
And the violence is
rarely unilateral--
and the context for these
displays of civil unrest
are very complicated indeed.
But there's one thing
that we believe,
which is that every voice in
the debate deserves to be heard.
And there's an observation
there that, typically,
if dissent is being cracked
down on in the physical world,
it's also being cracked down
on in the virtual world.
And if freedom of assembly
is deemed to be a threat,
then surely, so is
freedom of speech.
And in many ways, you
can think of a website
as being the 21st century
equivalent of an office.
So in the same way that the
physical presence of NGOs
and independent
media organizations
are being shut down, so are
their online virtual presences.
Another question--
how many people
have had before of a DDoS?
Wow, OK, about two-thirds.
Who put up their hand?
Can you put up your hand again?
Do you know what a
DDoS attack stands for?
OK, behind you.
Do you know?
Oh, everyone's just like, "Who?
Who?"
OK, another question.
Who here knows what a
DDoS attack stands for?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Denial of service.
YASMIN GREEN: Yes, exactly.
Denial of service.
It's distributed denial
of service attack, which
is basically flooding a
website with unwanted traffic
so that it can't stay up.
And there are very, very
many of these DDoS attacks
happening-- 20,000 plus a day.
And DDoS attacks are
responsible for one-third
of all server downtime.
And they are most
often politically
and ideologically motivated.
So these are a
really big program.
Guess what?
You can buy a DDoS attack.
And this one I found online.
This is actually, I
think, even expensive now
because I found this
three months ago,
and I think they're really
getting cheaper in price.
$100 on eBay to buy a botnet
that wages a DDoS attack.
So I'm sure you guys
know what a botnet is.
You kind of infect a network
of machines with malware,
and then you command and control
them like an army of computers.
So now we're in
this situation where
anyone can buy anyone else's
silence anywhere in the world
by buying a botnet.
In particular, a particular
risk are small websites
because they don't have the
infrastructure or the resources
to stay up when faced
with a flood of traffic.
And this is an example-- the
Kenyan election monitoring
webmasters told us
that, despite having
a website the whole time,
they've never actually managed
to stay up during the
presidential election itself.
We saw the guy talk about
[INAUDIBLE], an Iranian website
in the video clip.
They are blocked in Iran.
But even though they're
blocked, they still
suffer DDoS attacks every time
they write anything that's
politically controversial
because those pro-state actors
want to make triply
sure that nobody in Iran
can access that content,
even if they use a proxy.
So this is the
graph of four years
so that you can
see how prevalent
and how these attacks are,
and also how they're growing.
This is a pretty
worrying picture.
So other than the
people in this room, who
are impressive in terms
of having heard of DDoS
attacks before, most
people rarely, if ever,
hear about them.
Why is that?
Because they're invisible.
The threat's invisible.
Actually, the people that
we speak to-- the NGOs
that we speak to
or activists that
have suffered DDoS
attacks-- most often
don't even know what's happened
to them because it's invisible.
So they'll go into the browser
and they'll put in their URL,
and what do they see?
Nothing.
They ask their
friends and family
abroad to visit the site,
and they also see nothing.
The second problem
is that, of course,
we each only see just our
small corner of the internet.
No one really has
the big picture
to understand just how
big the problem is.
So that's why I want
to share with you--
that's why we
launched this website.
It's called-- it's at
digitalattackmap.com,
and it's based on
the premise that you
don't need to be a meteorologist
to understand a weather map.
So we wanted to create
a map of digital attacks
that anybody could
understand, that was
intuitive and
informative for anyone
who wanted to find out more.
And this is at
digitalattackmap.com,
so anyone who wants
to visit it can.
But if you want to take photos
of it, that's also good.
Let me just kind of
talk you through in case
you can't see the
legend-- how this works.
The shape of the lines
denote how much information
we know about the attack.
So if we know the origin
and the destination,
you see an arched line.
If we know just the
origin or the destination,
you see a vertical line
going into or coming out
of the country.
And if you see a
concentric circle,
that means that the
attack was internal,
so the origin and
the destination
were in the same country.
And then you can also
kind of color the map
by different variables-- type,
duration, the source port
origin of the attack,
or the destination
port where the
attack is targeted.
And the data-- I'm going get
you something pretty-- this
is just a day-by-day
of all of the attacks
that we've seen over
the last few months.
The data was provided by a
group called Arbor Networks, who
install DDoS mitigation
hardware at over 80% of ISPs
around the world.
And those ISPs then feed
back to Arbor anonymized data
on the attacks that
they've received,
and that's what's kind
of driving this map.
But I did want to
show you, actually,
a few interesting
moments specifically.
So we spoke before about
the real world protests
that we've seen over
the last few months.
If you scroll down
here to the timeline,
this is Thailand that
we're looking at.
And this is the timeline
of DDoS attacks.
And this is December 4.
And you'll notice, of
course, that December
was when the controversial
anti-government protests first
started.
And you can see that there's--
as is often the case,
but not always recognized--
there's a cyber spillover
to what we're seeing happen
in the real, physical world.
Let me show you another
interesting case study.
This is now China on August 27.
And you'll see a huge flood
of both volumetric and
connection-based attacks
that are landing in China.
If you scroll down,
the news results
are updated to reflect
the country, hopefully
relevant to DDoS
attacks, and they're
relevant for that
particular day.
So if we click on
a result, we can
see that, indeed,
China was attacked.
The attack targeted China's
domain name service,
so all the .cn websites.
And this attack
actually took out
a huge chunk of the
Chinese internet.
So it was pretty monumental.
And the last one--
this is October 2,
and we're looking
at the Philippines.
So this massive spike in
attacks against the Philippine
government, actually, was
allegedly waged by the hacker
group Anonymous in retaliation
for the Philippine government
passing a bill that
was interpreted
to be against free
expression online.
So we see many types
of attacks happen
for many types of reasons.
We said governments against
independent media sites--
actually, quite prevalent, kids
against their online gaming
rivals.
And of course--
[LAUGHTER]
Actually, one of
the biggest attacks
that is ever recorded
on history happened
in March of last year, which was
300 megabits per second, which
is the same as the entire
international bandwidth
of Spain.
And when they found
the person that did it,
it was a 16-year-old
boy in the UK
who had basically been playing
online games in his parents'
basement and had committed this.
So we get the idea.
One thing is really
clear-- that we
have something of a
DDoS issue on our hands.
And that takes us
to the next problem,
the problem of protection.
DDoS attacks can be used by
anyone to silence anyone else,
which hurts the internet, and
it hampers free expression.
And mapping it is a
really good first step,
but if you're being attacked,
that simply doesn't cut it.
Oh, and Google,
of course, we have
some of the world's leading
experts in DDoS mitigation
capabilities.
And we also have a core value
to protect free expression.
So we decided to
connect those dots.
I'm excited to tell you
about Project Shield.
Last year we
announced the launch
of a new project,
a new initiative,
that provides access to
Google's enormous infrastructure
to the websites that
are most vulnerable
and need it the most.
And it works by connecting
Google's DDoS mitigation
capabilities to a reverse proxy.
So those most vulnerable sites
can use Google's defenses
as their first line of defense
against malicious traffic
while still keeping that
own site and data locally
on their own servers.
The objective was to kind of put
our products where our values
are and keep the web's-- support
free speech and keep websites
up and running.
And we're looking for more.
So we've had some really
encouraging results so far.
The Kenyan election monitoring
site that I mentioned,
we kept them up during the
last presidential election.
We've helped websites in
Iran, Ukraine, Venezuela,
and we want to help more.
So in case you, yourself, run a
website that kind of qualifies
as being independent
media, human rights
advocacy, or
election monitoring,
or you know anyone
that does, then please
visit the link that's
being projected here--
projectshield.withgoogle.com--
and apply
to be protected by us.
It's free.
OK, so thank you for listening.
Thank you for being here.
And I guess I'll just leave
you with a question, which
is do you care about
moon shots, and do you
want to help the
next five billion
that are coming online in
conflict and repression?
And do you get a kick out
of working alongside people
like Slim Amamou who's
a personal hero of mine?
If you do, then the invitation
is here to join forces.
Thanks.
I don't think I
have time to do Q&A.
But if somebody tells
me to do it, I will.
FEMALE SPEAKER: You
can take two questions.
YASMIN GREEN: OK.
Anyone have any questions?
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
YASMIN GREEN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Nice talk.
Thank you.
I work for [INAUDIBLE],
actually, and Internews Kenya,
so we do a lot of
crisis mapping.
And we're looking
for developers,
so if anyone wants to
develop for crisis mapping,
we're totally into it.
But I have a question about
your relationship with Tor.
I know similar proxy services
that are more focused
on creating anonymity networks,
but also based on trust,
and uProxy seems to create more
of like an intimacy network.
So I'm curious about
that relationship.
YASMIN GREEN: Yeah,
that's a good question.
Does everyone here
know who Tor are?
Have you heard of Tor as a--
less people familiar with Tor?
OK, so Tor are one of the most
widely used proxies out there.
And honesty, they are
a group that Google
has supported in the past.
And the group that
are developing uProxy
are in close
communication with them.
So the critical
difference, and one
that I think is
really important,
is that Tor is anonymous.
So you don't
necessarily know when
you're participating in
the Tor network-- who
it is that's using
your computer.
You can just imagine
the types of concerns
you might have about why
somebody might want to navigate
anonymously through
the internet.
And the difference
with uProxy is
that it's just based on this
peer-to-peer trust network.
Having said that, you could
imagine some really cool spin
offs where you can kind of
make them interoperable.
So the cool thing
about this tool
is that it works
through just a browser
extension and or Gchat window
or your Facebook Chat window.
And so I think,
ideally, we would really
want to integrate with
them, going forward.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
YASMIN GREEN: Thanks
for your question.
AUDIENCE: First of all,
I can't tell you enough
how excited I am to hear this.
I was born and raised
in China for 25 years.
I stayed there for 25 years.
I had been personally
identified and threatened
for related-- just
posting free informations
on the internet when
I was still in China,
so this is very exciting.
But my question
is-- it's different.
So in the map, you
show the United States,
and it's in the color of yellow.
So I want to know
if we are, indeed,
as Americans, our own target
of rescue to any extent at all.
Could you elaborate at
least on the coloring--
the scheme of that?
YASMIN GREEN: Yeah, so-- I
mean, I showed it three times.
I guess I don't need to
show you that map anymore.
The map was-- I am so grateful
that there are organizations
that publish these reports
so that I don't personally
have to subjectively stay where
is free and where is not free.
But yeah, in that map--
so Freedom House--
a very well-respected
NGO that publish reports
on press freedoms
and other freedoms.
And in that map, the
US was not white,
which was the absolute best.
There were five categories.
The USA was yellow.
So is your question
do I personally
think if the USA
should have been white?
AUDIENCE: No.
It's--
YASMIN GREEN: OK.
Phew.
AUDIENCE: Do we
have areas, I guess,
to improve to being
white, I guess.
More free-- union
we free ourselves,
or do we have work to do?
YASMIN GREEN: I actually
don't know that question.
I'm going to look
at specifically--
I think Freedom House
actually give their rationale.
They have
country-specific reports,
and I should have been
prepared with that.
So I'll go and look at
why specifically they
see the USA isn't white.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
YASMIN GREEN: Good question.
Thank you.
Thanks.
OK, I know I'm--
FEMALE SPEAKER: Sorry, guys.
We're just--
YASMIN GREEN: Thank you so much.
Thanks for having me.
Get in touch.
Thanks.